David.
I see Joe Biden has a nice lead, but how can
he keep the lead for two months and prevent
it from slipping away?
So the numbers are looking pretty good for
Joe Biden.
Earlier this week, we compared Joe Biden's
polling to that of Hillary Clinton.
Exactly four years ago.
And we found that on September 8th, which
was Tuesday.
Joe Biden was up seven point one compared
to Hillary Clinton being up only 2.5 on that
same date in 2016.
So that's good.
At this point, this election is going to fundamentally
come down to turnout and foul play.
Very few people are going to change their
minds between the candidates in the time that
is left.
I don't want to pretend that the swing voter
doesn't exist.
I don't want to pretend that some people are
undecided, as insane as it sounds to be undecided
right now.
Some people are undecided.
I'd love to meet them.
Please call into my show.
I want to talk to you.
But they do exist.
The big factors from here on out are going
to be turnout and avoiding some of the voter
suppression that clearly Donald Trump plans
to do.
So in terms of what Joe Biden can actually
do, No.
One in the debates, you've got to avoid a
big mistake if you make the debates at this
point are not going to change many minds unless
you make a big mistake.
And even then, what they will likely do is
keep some people home.
You might have people who are leaning Biden
if Biden were to make a really embarrassing
mistake during the debates.
I don't even know what it would be.
You could have some of those voters who say
not I'm voting for Trump, but I'm going to
stay home.
Joe Biden also must encourage early voting,
early in-person voting and voting absentee.
We also have to remember the vaccine surprise
is coming even if it's B.S.
We already talked about it today.
The vet, the vaccine surprise is coming in
October.
Trump will almost certainly announce emergency
use for a vaccine.
We got it.
Even if doses aren't available for a long
time.
And Joe Biden needs to be ready to counter
out.
Can't counteract that.
And then what can the Democratic Party do
to make sure that every absentee ballot is
counted, that every mail in ballot is counted
because it is quite possible this Red Mirage
scenario is quite possible.
Red Meraj, meaning Trump seems to be winning
on election night.
Small margins in a few states puts him ahead
electorally.
And then as the absentee ballots are counted,
which are more likely to be Joe Biden votes
than Trump votes because Biden voters are
taking the virus more seriously, they're more
likely to want to vote vote by mail.
You see the lead start to shrink.
The Missouri the Wisconsin lead starts to
shrink.
Maybe the Pennsylvania lead starts to shrink.
And in advance of Biden taking a lead, Trump
deploys the lawyers.
Biden and Democrats need a strategy.
So I don't think it's as much about Biden's
lead slipping.
Winning by seven, seven weeks out from the
election is a huge deal for me.
It's more about avoiding mistakes, but fighting
the voter suppression and the vote by mail
antics and the legal mechanisms that Donald
Trump will use if the Democratic Party were
smart.
I don't know if they're smart.
If the Democratic Party were proactive.
I'm not sure that they're proactive.
They would have a legal strategy with hundreds,
thousands of like I don't know how many lawyers
you need.
Plenty of lawyers ready to ensure that no
court stops the counting of absentee ballots.
That is, unfortunately, what this may come
down to.
Reminder, voting starts soon.
Illinois early voting starts 40 days before
the election.
That's like two weeks from now.
Maine starts 30 days before the election.
That's three weeks from now.
Michigan, you can start early voting 45 days
before the election.
That's two weeks away.
Minnesota, Montana, Nebraska, New Jersey,
a lot of these states.
You can start early voting 30 to 45 days before
the election.
The election is now.
Let's not regret this on November 4th.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Remember, you can get instant access to the
bonus show by becoming a member instantly
at join Pacman dot com.